I live in North Carolina and in the past few weeks
I've seen the devastating impact
that Hurricane Helena's had on my friends,
my family, my communities.
But something that I haven't seen enough people talking about
is the devastating impact this Hurricane has had on reproductive care
in my state. In Western North Carolina,
there is one abortion clinic, Ashville,
which is one of the cities that was hit the hardest
when Hurricane Helene swept through North Carolina.
As of today, it is still non operative and non functioning
because of the impact the Hurricane had on Ashville's water supply.
70% of Ashville still without water
including the clinic. Carolina has a restrictive 12 week ban.
We are surrounded, especially on the western side of North Carolina,
by states with even more restrictive or total abortion bans. Tennessee,
Georgia, South Carolina.
Making this single plan parenthood in Asheville
that is now non functioning place
for many in those states with restrictive bans
would come when they could not get care in their own home states.
Facility being non operative also hurts the local community
because they now don't have access to free or low cost birth control,
emergency contraception.
Things also prevent pregnancies in the first place.
The scope of damage to the natural disasters cause is vast.
Couple with all these restrictive bands also in place
in these southern states
where natural disasters tend to hit most often,
they have devastated reproductive rights.